now at 7 30 as the sun comes up on this
sad day of remembrance an anniversary of
january 6th one year later the capitol
police are saying that threats to
lawmakers are at an all-time high and
the surge has forced the department to
remake itself so we can better track
down those behind the threats our chris
van cleeve got exclusive access to the
department's efforts and learned how
lawmakers
are being intimidated 365 days later
chris good morning to you good morning
tony we got to warn you some of the
language in this report is graphic you
know we had no problem finding lawmakers
who are receiving disturbing threats but
we really struggled to find one who had
talked to us on camera they feared
prompting more threats and normalizing
what is otherwise violent violent vile
behavior what you're about to hear is
anything but normal
i hope your family dies in front of you
i pray that god if you've got any
children they died in your face do you
get calls like that a lot i do we get
several of those a week congresswoman
debbie dingle says threats like this
ramped up after former president trump
attacked her and her late husband john
at a campaign rally in december 2019.
debbie dingle that's a real beauty and
he
made very public comments about john
looking up from hell
and i was just stunned by it it's not
only verbal abuse in november her
dearborn michigan office was vandalized
i had men in front of my
house with assault weapons
after
tucker carlson had done a rant on me
what is the impact on
debbie the person not the the
congresswoman i'm trying not to let it
get to me but it doesn't mean that
some nights when you're home and alone
and you don't have the husband you love
anymore you don't get scared do you
worry that by talking to us you're gonna
get more threats probably i don't think
most people understand the amount of
vitriol the the challenging
communications a member of congress and
their staff would get
at any given time for over 20 years phd
psychologist mario scalora has worked
with the capitol police analyzing
threats made against lawmakers we're
seeing more people out there putting out
more threatening rhetoric
we're seeing more people out there
justifying violence in their rhetoric
this is the most concern i've ever had
in 20 years
roughly 9 600 threats were referred to
the department last year alone about a
thousand more than they saw in 2020
cbs news obtained more than a dozen
voicemails targeting both sides
california democrat adam schiff shift
these shifts i will put a bullet in your
forehead michigan republican fred upton
your piece of trader i hope you die i
hope everybody in your
family dies scolora says the rise in
threats is a direct reflection of our
current political discourse do you feel
like you can keep up we're being
stretched
let's be blunt we're being stretched
we're keeping up
but this is not an ideal situation in
new york this man pleaded not guilty to
making a terroristic threat after he
allegedly left a dead rat with a noose
around its neck on the doorstep of
republican tom reed the brother of
democrat hakeem jeffries was threatened
by a california man claiming to be armed
and nearby we played this threatening
voicemail for scolora
it was left for wyoming senator cynthia
lummus after she voted against
impeaching former president trump you
committed treason you've committed
sedition and i will kill you i will i
will kill you where's the red flag
someone is making a direct threat to
life
and they're expressing that they want to
carry it out and that they're willing to
carry it out that is going to get our
serious and due attention the sender a
52 year old laramie man is now serving
18 months in prison where does
behavior move from protected speech
to a criminal threat a threat to life is
not protected speech plain and simple
last year the capitol police flagged
about
460 such threats we're keeping up but
it's a challenge chief tom manger is
tasked with remaking the capitol police
are lawmakers
and the capital are they more at risk
today than they were a year ago i don't
know if it's more but it's at a level
where it's it's higher than it should be
threats also rise when members of
congress take rhetorical aim at
colleagues after colorado republican
lauren bobert likened democrat ilhan
omar to a suicide bomber both received
threats omar playing this one publicly
freighter
you will not live much longer but i
can
almost guarantee you that these are the
kinds of threats that that we get
on a daily basis
the capitol police gave us exclusive
access to the training its officers now
get as the department looks to directly
investigate more of these threats and
rely less on other agencies how
concerned are you that somebody's going
to get hurt very concerned i'm concerned
about everybody's safety here and
understand that at a moment's notice at
a moment's notice something could happen
that we're not anticipating his
intelligence unit has doubled the number
of analysts available to monitor the
threat landscape especially online and
the agency is looking to add 280 new
officers this year if we want to really
get to a point where
where we want to be where we should be
it's going to take more time to get more
people in place dingle believes to
change course voters need to hold
politicians accountable for their tone
at the polls we all need to think about
what we're saying to each other what
we're doing to each other you know who i
really worry about is the kids the young
people in our office who believe in
public service who believe in our
democracy who are frequently
the ones that hear those messages first
the capitol police is opening field
offices to investigate these threats
more efficiently the first two are in
florida and california the states where
they say the most threats originate
chris it's a powerful piece it's also a
reminder that the majority of the people
who stormed this building a year ago
today were not known members of
extremist groups or militia groups they
were everyday americans it speaks to the
mainstreaming of these threats yeah the
threats the one commonality is these are
people that have a grievance they just
can't let go of all right chris thank
you very much gail as i throw it back to
you i can't help but think can you
imagine calling somebody up knowing
you're being recorded and leaving a
voicemail like the ones we just heard
i really can't tony i'm still stunned by
it it was absolutely chilling it's still
i can't get over the fact that these are
still americans against americans i
still have a hard time wrapping my brain
around that and those videos that
imagery still just makes me ill today
thank you so much